Welcome back everyone it's Charlie. Marvel and
Sony just announced the title of Venom 3 there's
some deep cut Easter eggs and connections I know
there's tons of questions about how to pay off the
Venom symbiote post-credits scene in Spider-Man 4
in the new Tom Holland MCU Spider-Man trilogy all
the movies that are happening right now both
Spider-Man 4 Venom 3 all the related movies
like Kraven the hunter everything is meant to
eventually build up to Big crossovers Sinister
Six crossovers in Avengers six Secret Wars so
we'll break it all down if you're brand new to
the channel be sure to subscribe to get all the
videos speaking of Spider-Man crossovers in the
Multiverse Spider-Man across the spiderverse
that movie is a huge part of all this too
they'll incorporate some of those characters in
live action using some cool twists during those
spider-verse movies but the new title for Venom 3
is Orwell which first reference brings to mind is
George Orwell who wrote 1984 Animal Farm pretty
much every kid of a certain age in America had to
read Animal Farm during grade school 1984 is all
about totalitarianism total control pure power
propaganda machines in it's been referenced in
tons of Pop Culture all kinds of media for many
many years but I think the larger Easter egg for
Orwell might actually be for the original Venom
lethal protector Marvel Comics that they based
the character on originally in that first movie
everything with a life Foundation the Carlton
Drake character Venom fighting the other symbios
the Orwell Taylor character is an ex United States
military General who creates an evil group a team
called the jury appearing in the lethal protector
storyline through the first couple of issues Venom
wound up killing one of his sons he goes mad with
grief swears revenge on him and steals Iron Man's
armor technology yes they're Iron Man connections
because he also had a lot of Spider-Man crossovers
too he uses Iron Man's armors to upgrade his
other Sons their friends to specifically take
out Venom as the team called the jury like they're
meant to be the judge juries and executioners of
Venom they fail hard then they wind up going
after Spider-Man instead to force him to help
them they start working with the life foundation
and after the police discover all the craziest
stuff that they got up to the legal stuff trying
to kill Venom Orwell winds up being arrested and
that's pretty much the end of it the last time he
appeared in the comics was during the 90s that's
how long ago it was but that's where a lot of
these stories that they based the Venom movies
on are from he bounced back and forth between
the Venom comics and the Spider-Man comics so
Spider-Man would end up helping take him down just
as much as Venom did for those of you wondering
if they're going to give Spider-Man the Venom
symbiote during Secret Wars is a reference to
the origin of the Symbiote in the comics just
because there is that whole post-credit scene
like how are they gonna deal with that as far
as I've heard they're not going to use Secret
Wars to do a comic book Easter egg there might
be some light references to it during that but
I believe they're going to pay off the Symbiote
during Tom Holland's next Spider-Man trilogy the
solo movies themselves but not till the sequels
like Spider-Man 5 or Spider-Man 6. they've already
revealed a bunch of details about Spider-Man
4 and it doesn't sound like there's a lot of
symbiote stuff going on during that for the most
part it's happening during Marvel Phase 5 so it's
part of the dark rain era when Kingpin becomes
mayor of New York City in the idea with Kingpin
is that he takes a very anti-vigilante stance so
Spider-Man is trying to be friendly neighborhood
Spider-Man being a vigilante saving people in
New York City while the Kingpin is using all of
his resources like the law all this above board
stuff to stop people like Spider-Man Daredevil
the Punisher all the other good Vigilantes from
actually doing their jobs so Kingpin can do all
the Shady stuff that he wants to I do believe
that Daredevil and Kingpin will have cameos
in the movie I know at least Daredevil will
I don't know how big Kingpin is going to be
in but they did say that what Kingpin is doing
during Daredevil born again will be a big plot
point during Spider-Man 4 even if Kingpin
himself isn't going to be one of the main
villains of Spider-Man 4. they haven't said who
the main villain of Venom 3 is supposed to be
yet but they did have the big teaser for talks
and at the end of Venom Let There Be Carnage the
Symbiote who's the child of Carnage winds up
bonding with Detective Mulligan in the comics
and at the end of the movie his eyes glowed
he started yelling about monsters and freaks
monsters
they could always swerve on that if they wanted to
go in a totally different direction but there's a
strong chance that he winds up being at least
one of the villains in the movie in addition
to some new characters from the comics Juno
Temple was announced for the cast she could
wind up being a version of the phage character
from the lethal protector storyline even though
there was a yellow symbiote during the first
Venom movie that had died I don't think they
ever specifically called it phage in the movie
so they could still use that character or they
could just give her the toxin symbiote or
they could make her a completely different
character from the comics they haven't said which
other sinister six characters are going to Cameo
either just because all this is taking place
on the same Earth if it wasn't clear all the
Sony Marvel movies all these Spider-Man spin-off
movies that they're doing like they're doing all
the Venom movies they just did the morbius movie
It's morbin time they're releasing the Kraven the
hunter movie later this year I actually just did a
trailer video from Cinema console I'll post a link
for that down in the description below and at the
end of this because it looks like it's going to be
hardcore it will be an R-rated movie there's
the Madame Web movie there's that other spy
Spider-Woman movie there's just a lot of related
movies that are all building up towards sinister
six movies that was the whole point of the morbius
post-credits scene is letting you know that they
were trying to build up to a Sinister Six
movie where they would fight a version of
Spider-Man but they didn't say which version
of Spider-Man has to do with Spider-Man I think
still figuring this place out but I think a bunch
of guys like us should team up could do some good
right now all the rumors are saying that it's
going to be Andrew Garfield's version I don't
know how reliable those are because it's just
a rumor but there were so many Easter eggs for
Venom and all the stuff that they're doing right
now in the Sony Marvel movies back when they were
doing the Andrew Garfield Amazing Spider-Man
movies and wondered if the morbius movie is
actually happening in Andrew Garfield's Amazing
Spider-Man universe of movies there are some Toby
Maguire Spider-Man references and Easter eggs
in the trailer like the Toby Maguire Spider-Man
suit with the Tom Holland Mysterio plot points
the version of The Daily Bugle newspaper that
morbius is reading is the Tobey Maguire version
with the Daily Bugle logos from his films and
even though the building looks a little bit
different the version of Oscorp is the Andrew
Garfield Amazing Spider-Man version and The
Daily Bugle mentions the Rhino the black cat
characters who were both characters in Amazing
Spider-Man 2. if you don't remember there were
some deleted scenes with Felicia Hardy she was
eventually going to turn into a version of black
cat like they had at Felicia Hardy assistant at
Oscorp but she had not become black cat yet Perry
get out
that would have been a big Amazing Spider-Man 3
moment so I will reference Amazing Spider-Man 3
because there were a lot of references to that
during Spider-Man no way home and it sounds like
here during the morbius trailer if it's been
a while since you've seen Amazing Spider-Man
2 during that movie you might remember they
referenced morbius and Venom specifically along
with a bunch of other teasers for other characters
and things buried in Harry Osborne's Oscorp Files
like zoom and enhance here they have a morbius
project that they were working on they had a
Venom project so had they made Amazing Spider-Man
3 with Andrew Garfield they would have given him
the Venom symbiote during that movie and he would
have faced a version of the Sinister Six as they
teased in the post-credits scene but we also would
have seen a version of black cat show up and then
obviously they were trying to set up a whole
bunch of other spin-off movies too the funny
thing about that a lot of people will remember
this it wasn't that long ago it seems like it
was a long time ago but it wasn't that's how many
times they've rebooted Spider-Man during Amazing
Spider-Man 2 there were all kinds of references to
all the stuff that you see happening right now in
the current movies during Spider-Man no way home
Andrew Garfield Spider-Man even said he wanted to
fight an alien after they started talking about
fighting black goo aliens versions of Venom I
fought a an alien made out of black goo once oh
no way I found alien too oh yeah he was purple I
want to fight an alien you can let me know in
the comments do you actually think that Andrew
Garfield will come back to do something like
that or will they just find a completely new
version of Spider-Man or someone who will not take
the mask off so they can just be ambiguous about
which version of Spider-Man it is it sounds
like it will be a couple more years before
they actually do work up to a genuine Sinister
Six Solo movie like they'll build it to a new
Trilogy of sinister six movies and that's probably
where Tom Hardy's Venom character will go after
Venom 3 if they don't do more Venom movies like
I don't know if they're gonna do a Venom 4. the
original Amazing Spider-Man 2 post credit scene
teasing that Sinister Six was actually meant to
build up to a completely separate franchise
like they were gonna make Amazing Spider-Man
3 set up sort of a symbiote Saga a Venom Saga
for Andrew Garfield Spider-Man but separately
also do a spin-off Trilogy for the Sinister Six
although sinister six characters that was not for
Amazing Spider-Man 3. so it just sounds like Sony
went back to the drawing board they're like okay
let's try that plan again let's do a Sinister Six
Trilogy and that'll just be where we take some of
the more popular characters after this and if some
of them aren't popular we can just cycle in brand
new characters the funny thing about Sony still
having the rights to Spider-Man is that a part of
those they have the rights to over 900 characters
but even without crossing the characters over in
secret Wars with all the MCU characters like Tom
Hall and Spider-Man which they're already in the
process of doing they could still do their own
version of an Avengers Infinity war in an Avengers
end game event with like the null character
there's so much more Lauren Cannon from the
comics that they can do that they can continue to
escalate for many many years before they have to
do some sort of reboot or reimagining again let me
know in the comments though if they do work up to
a Sinister Six spin-off franchise and that does
get a Trilogy what else do you want them to do
with the characters which other character do you
want to see during that the good news is it does
sound like based on all the footage from cinemacon
the Kraven movie actually does have a legit chance
of being pretty decent everyone click here for my
Kraven the hunter trailer video to learn what's
going on with that movie and click here for my
brand new secret Invasion trailer video and Easter
eggs thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!